on va jouer avec les chansons de patrick
bruel c'est mon ami jean luc lemoine qui
a trouvé un petit peu ce jeu parce qu'il
voulait seulement de faire un jouer
contre patrick webb alors vous voyez une
aura sur un trampoline
c'est normal ces juifs à mon poste jean
luc lemoine auquel jdle et on joue à
quoi et autres on peut dégringoler
des clins d'oeil à des réglages du jeu
est très simple
alors expliquer alors il on va donner
des morceaux de phrases des chansons de
patrick bruel c'est ça celui qui
reconnaît la chanson buzz mais il doit
la chanter attendez s'est appuyé sur
cette route rocheuses et doit chanter la
chanson sinon le point n'est pas valable
et donc les indices sont dans les
ballons kenora va éclater oui ça c'était
le truc logique que jal expliqué juste
après
il ya des papiers avec des paroles de
chansons de patrick bruel vous allez
jouer donc chez vous également et
jean-luc on doit chanter la chanson
exactement alors moi je ramasse un
indice je vous lis j'ai cherché j'ai
cherché des trucs pour ligne message est
pas prêt ça ça c'est que ces gros steak
suspense autour de votes et laura
allez-y alors vas tu as we know now vous
inquiétez pas personne ne regardera ça
on n'est pas là pour ça on n'est
vraiment pas la bourse on est là pour
bosser alesi droit la vache
allez-y subi mais c'est vrai qu'on a
tous jaloux et j'adore parce que le truc
l'hôtel à ce jour une culture
rires vous à l'âge que j'ai mis une
grosse culotte c'est bon c'est pas que
ça par les génois si habile à bien dans
l'émission on n'aura pas besoin de kyoto
n'est pas le pâté à rien alors remis
lundi ce ça alors figure alors le
premier dit c'est ce soir j'ai envie les
deux soirs j'ai envie de me casser la
voix cassée cassé
g
sa nature
l'homme était partout s'il vous plaît je
fais n'omettez pas partout n'a pas envie
rentrer là dedans allez jean luc lemoine
donc on va pas une fois ces comptages
des paroles de chansons qu'ils trouvent
buzz va les attentions
j'ai très bien qu'à ce jeu jamais
personne ne regarde tu sais très bien ce
qu'elle dit lequel de nous manger des
petits fours la chanter allez dans
lequel sera à lire les silences playback
ya plus bas que l'algérie guérilla
l'attendait son frère de laure et pas de
point vient pas de moi parce que parce
que ya eu ce jeudi le titre au milan ac
bayer j'ai fait ce que j'ai fait les
gros yeux j'en ai année si on retourne
encore un ballon encore
trouvez papier
je rappelle que ces gars
champion olympique a en tout cas on peut
dire on peut dire qu'elle y met du coeur
et les adieux des noirs malgré un tee
shirt marqué comme des c est juste qu il
faut l'acheter il faut la chaudrée cela
change t il la connaît pas un concert
des stones unsa la barre est la preuve
du succès je me regarde je me ferais un
chemin au milieu d'anji elle reprend la
main je veux bien longtemps
c'est le fond
bonjour je viens d anjou le dernier à
aller au delà des tensions attention
attention il aura tendance à ne pas
aller de l'autre côté et laura milieu
pense à ta famille fait pas de conneries
ce jour l'on sera aller allons-y
c'est parti je rappelle enora va éclater
un balayage speed 8 a mal aux yeux
alors regardons c'est quoi alors regarde
avec un oeil droit
non c'est non non mais n'oubliez bluffé
j'ai dit mais chedjou tableau juste oui
mais j'ai très envie non c'est jésus va
pas me taire parce que
dernière
m
c'est quoi muscler vite non la prochaine
fois c'est pas pour patrick ça se joue
là dessus autre événement c'est bon il
est si vers lui quand même à résidence
elle est fatiguée allait bien et bâle
ont baissé pavillon 2 et un magot elle
avait de la boue a fait le doublé
attention attention attention les
paroles de la chanson c'est le baiser
qui fait mal aux baisers petit à mal les
mauvais jours mais mon amour sur les
chansons velours abb
à marseille et
bon